plus it's only round four of the world
championship and again it was a draw
Magnus was pressing for a long time
and Kuryakin again showed his defensive
skills today and by the time you see
this presumably this match is already
over but I thought we'd have a little
bit of fun today you don't think so it's
just never going to end
yeah probably not so first you'll come
back I thought we'd have a little fun
today and we look at the top 10 most
amazing tactics in World Championships
ever all time amazing excellence so in
this position now we're going to go to
at number 10 really quick all these are
going to be tactics from world
championship games
this was Magnus Carlsen versus
Vishwanath in Anand ought to remember
which of their encounters it was by
making this a lot smaller this one was
from 2014 and we're going to get to the
positions so black played f4 this is
Carlsen is white here and he took which
which maybe was a little bit of a
mistake and suddenly Carlsen species all
kind of came to life here after this so
now the rook comes in and okay you can
see White's pieces are suddenly becoming
very active and in this position we'll
pause now you can pause at home can you
find the tactic that Carlson found in
the game
and I'll give you guys you know a couple
minutes here to think about it
you got it already was it the suggestion
maybe took on f7 first but yeah this is
sort of di the idea I guess he took on
f7 first okay this is this is the idea
with the idea of it there's some some
pins here going on in this direction in
the game I see I should I took on f7
first which is probably stronger and now
this idea is still works so he token
okay again the idea is if you take then
rook c1 and I get one of your bishops at
least so in the game he went here and
Carlsen being the technical player that
he is as we really saw today I hh4 was a
good idea you can't really ever take
because then I push my pawns and Carlsen
went on to win this game okay
all right easy next now this will be
number nine and this whole game is one
big tactic so we'll watch the whole
thing this is Alexander Ali ekend vs.
max Ave and obviously I can't read the
year when I get really tiny so you guys
can't read the years but maybe I have a
chance this is from 1937 okay and the
whole whole game is pretty tactical so
they play this very sharp line
so it's not quite yeah this is sort of
one of these these funny slobs where
than you there's all sorts of crazy
complicated lines you can try to play b5
right away you can play what's in the
game which I think it's one of the
better ways to play but uh don't expect
a lot of opening theory from this game
ok and he took which is interesting if
you can get away with it and black took
on d4 and we calmly play Knight f3
so it's interesting question can you
take the night or not all right in this
position black played b5 which is a huge
blunder if you take the night we take on
f7 and you can't you can't take you can
play King here and then okay I don't
want to trade Queens so Queen b3 you
could try this you know you're up a
piece in all but I don't really like
your chances with your King on e7 so
this should be avoided but more than
that this should also be avoided so we
will pause here so you can think at home
pause the video would you guys play here
as white you've seen this this game yeah
yeah yeah white did this yeah very good
that's the hint
so yeah if you haven't found it at home
you can go ahead and pause just do that
he took on b5 now I assume maybe black
saw that and he tried to be you know a
little trickster but first let's have a
look at what happens if we do take here
what did white have in mind there's 55
yeah and the rooks kind of trapped over
there it's you're not going to protect
it so that's the that's the whole point
but he thought it'd be a little tricky
Bishop a6 all right
I mean this what are you going to do
play Queen b3 attacking f7 you still
can't take because Bishop d5 also I mean
you take care of the mission t5 but okay
protected here and he just kind of soul
soon
that you didn't remember ok so again you
can't do this Bishop d5 so you decided
to take this way ok I take back and now
if you take me instead of Bishop d5 its
Queen d5 so it's the same sort of deal
so he didn't take back he finally you
know develops his Knight because it's
move ten and okay so why it actually is
you know he's just winning now in this
position he just saves his bishop will
watch the conclusion of the game but
from this point it's already kind of
over though he won in really pretty
fashion which is you know very important
all right so now he pins this Knight to
the rook and you attack my Bishop and
there's lots of ways to win but he
picked a pretty exciting way he took
here with the point that if you take
this way I can trade Queens and then
take your rook on b8 so he took here
lots of trading and I take this guy I'm
on your book and you know this just
takes and pins a guy and okay here the
game came to its conclusion so you know
it kind of reminds you maybe of the
accountant the Duke where one side is
way more developed and they play b5 and
these types of sacrifices are very
common in these types of positions you
know you can't just move on your pawns
you got to develop your stuff so that
was number nine coming in at number
eight this is the game between josé raúl
capablanca and a manual asker okay
so Kaplan Blanca has the white pieces
here he played check and he brought his
rook to c7 so white has quite a lot of
activity here and here we'll pause so
again go ahead and pause your videos at
home what moved to white play in this
position can you play like kappa blanka
Queen takes the knight exactly and here
he just resigned the point is yeah the
rook mates so yeah very nice finish
it's not often in a World Championship
you get to sack your queen but when you
do it must feel pretty good yeah I mean
he actually it's funny cuz he's not
really known for his tactical attacking
ability but he actually has a lot of
games where he really showed that he's
pretty sharp at tactics and you can
attack too it's just those games people
don't watch for some reason when what
you're keeping track of which number
we're on because I'm number seven okay
this is the game between Mikhail
Botvinnik and we call it all no tactics
tactic puzzle from World Championships
would be complete without at all game
and in this position this isn't this
isn't the tactic yet my question is
something different what did tall play I
don't want to know what the best move is
I want to know what did tall play that's
that's all all you need to know
it might be good maybe could be bad
nobody knows but I'll never stop him
from playing it in this position
complete Knight f4 which is sort of a
tempting sacrifice and okay when it's
tall
doesn't matter if it's entirely correct
or not that's for his opponent to figure
out you know so he took and he is sort
of famous for saying there's two kinds
of sacrifices correct ones and mine and
here the computer finds a very very
brilliant way to get an advantage with
white his opponent did not find it and
that is you know what he's known for the
most sort of semi correct sacrifices
that you know put the opponent into the
position where you have to be able to
try to find the refutation and it's
never easy you can pause if you want to
see if you can play like stockfish here
but the computer calmly just plays a3
and after you move just take the pawn
and as a human you might notice it's not
easy to retreat that bishop so you might
worry is my bishop going to get trapped
so we might consider a move like rook to
a8 although the computer doesn't mind
looks like all right Knight to b5 what's
the problem you know and then if you
remember on your rooks and all sorts of
stuff so if you trade now my nice
protected and I'm all tangled up but all
right I got a pawn I grabbed it I got it
no problem not good for human yeah when
you see your pieces all tangled up and
uncoordinated like that even if you
considered that option it's still hard
to play because there might be something
you don't see and somehow you remove one
defender and you take the other piece
you know so that that can kind of happen
so wait so not that move not a3 and you
have to play a3 of course first so
instead he just moved just Bishop back
hey I got the piece I moved back
and black decides to take the pond
alright so he's willing to give an
exchange away so I guess if you take
let's let's do this I guess you have to
go here what was the problem maybe this
was a this is a problem there's some
problems here if you actually take this
you point the move f3
and he took the Queen which is a mistake
though it's a very tempting move now go
ahead and pause your video see if you
can find the 20 move computer all forces
continuation good luck but what you
could play to get a small advantage with
white is the following you know crazy
forced line like every moves computers
like yeah all forced you know take stuff
you know no problem and you can find all
these moves and whites a little bit
better now his opponent did not find
that because he's a human I don't know
how much of that he must have considered
it surely a move that might come to mind
you know something you know this a movie
you want to consider you want to weigh
this versus this and this is what Paul
does he Marquis the water and you have
to figure it out and his opponent in he
took here which is a blunder and now he
takes the clean and will just show the
end of the game here but uh like it's
his pieces here to some some pretty
active squares
give the rook a little poke and in this
position he ones some material and then
okay he went on to win the game so I
don't even remember how much longer this
lasted I think it still lasts forever
then yeah I need to win yeah and then so
here the game came to its end
so okay a very very good game what do we
all know well number one run six this is
the game this is number six probably
between Tigran Petrosian and we call
Botvinnik this was played in 1963 okay
and this position Petrosian already has
a pretty good position taking on a seven
now with a queen is very good move but
he decides to go here starting to
undermine the Queen side is it being
funny
it's not your kind of humor okay that
was the screen I saw it like flicker
okay so here we're going to pause our
videos again let's see now if we can
play like Petrosian so pause your videos
at home and I'll give you guys a minute
here to see if we can find the tactic
all right can West on the ball Bishop d6
this is what was played in the game the
point is if you take the bishop which
was not played we can take here on your
queen and your rook and we'd go here and
we'd win some material now probably
rooks e7 and all sorts of bad stuff is
happening so in the game he went here
and he wants the material which i think
is the end of it okay then he went on he
went on to win but that was the tactic
all right number five
number so this was a very interesting
game this was Vladimir Kramnik versus
Peter Lake Oh from 2004 and it was a
Marshall gambit
so you'll notice black is down upon but
here he gets a lot of activity by
challenging the e-file and now he's
going to bring his bishop in white took
here Bishop d3 and the safe move is
probably Queen to d1 the white one here
thinking he has a trick up his sleeve
okay this is obviously a move that we've
sort of allowed lies white allowed this
well okay you take what's the point you
in here and okay if you have to for
example give this Bishop up to prevent
queening then perhaps this is correct by
white but what move here did white
overlook and the tactics are going to
start getting harder we did some some
kind of simple ones see how far you can
actually get with it see how far you can
you can calculate at home and see if you
can work your way all the way through it
so it's black to move and yeah so
there's a move here that you know
Kramnik must have missed
or underestimated than those okay we
have assistance c5 if this is the
diagonal you're trying to open I will
probably push and that's yeah this is
the big problem is I'm I'm cleaning so
you do have to be you got to be fast you
can take here and in this position I
mean you can take this and then
something like this might even be close
to equal it's not necessarily that you
have a devastating new attack here with
black anymore
you had to give away some of your stuff
you get a strange imbalance that you
know nobody can figure out what's the
imbalance here but that is sort of the
thing so if you do that it's you know
probably about equal there's nothing
special so if you want to win I mean you
need to find some aggressive attacking
moves in this position and if you don't
find it then maybe you can you know bail
out by taking the pond in d3 is the
first movie on perhaps is opponent did
not see this or didn't think this was
such a big deal
he played King f2 okay continue
or 94 is attempting no it's tempting
yeah I was gonna take this way
it's something I just don't see what
your exact follow-up is going to be in
this position
yeah we kind of do want to play it move
like 94 okay we can't because everything
is attacking that square
yeah that's what he played Bishop takes
f3
okay now I'm coming in so you better
take now that 94 yeah
okay so congrats if you got this far
did you see the next move and without
this next move this whole combination
might not be correct then takes g3 okay
let's examine that okay I don't want to
take it well so I guess sure let's not
get made
in this position okay you want to take
what the bishop instead she's
interesting now I have to take it what
was your plan our each other you're not
checkmating me are you don't check me me
just just don't checkmate me okay don't
checkmate me all right your turn don't
checkmate me
you don't think I run away I'm running
away just just I'm gonna get Queen no
checkmates so this wasn't played and I
don't think this is exactly correct yeah
yeah let's try again so again I home you
may want to pause if you haven't found
it yet
I'll give the audience a little bit more
time here where's the white bishop yeah
this is this is yeah so this is the
position and it's black to move I take C
three Canwest again I'm fired tonight
and this is indeed the tactic and this
is how the game continued and yeah so we
can get the pawn at any time and in this
position okay it's it's over so white
resigned
yes I was a very good one let's just we
can just we can relive this one it was a
fun one
so wait yeah again so he thought he had
this cool little trick because I'm you
know about to Queen you get better do
something about it but Queen d3 here
followed by a couple spectacular
sacrifices alright so this is number
this is four
that was five that we just did didn't it
note to myself what actually happened
here so we'll go through the game sherry
let's watch the whole thing well see if
we find any tactics you guys let me know
if you see any tactics do see if we can
find any any good tactics in this game
okay and here again so they are getting
a little more complicated that's going
to require you to think a little bit
longer and if you you know you think
you're onto a good continuation try to
see how far you can go with it make sure
you you calculate accurately here let's
see how deep you guys can think about
this position its weight to move this is
a non tupelov 2010
nine f6 is a good move
it wasn't played but this move works as
well okay and what did you think black
would play we check check what move did
you think he'd play here I'll make a
move if you don't answer I'll make a
move your turn yeah you didn't have a
move after this so just that's just kind
of fun also you if I take here
what's your queen goes there
I also Mets there and now okay let's see
what your idea is
and that's it this is good this just
works yeah in this sacrifice actually
does work I think what he chose is a
little bit cleaner yeah he took the
h-bond
yes I think yeah so you just take the H
Pond and h6 you take back Queen h6 cuz
yeah you're going to give up a piece so
you better be
you better be dead on if you're going to
do that in the World Championship yeah
won't it be nice yeah to somehow lift
rook up and over all right so right yeah
yeah maybe Queen g5 is annoying f6 yeah
you're right as your idea okay so what
yeah what is the follow-up here this
term h3 is a good move
it's not what was played but this is a
very good move I'll go here
and then here you can play the MOOC that
was played in the game this is good yeah
but it's not what he actually decided to
play in the game and tried to move e5
clearing away for a rook lift okay so
you took the bishop
so you had to have seen this and then
found the right move in this position
which I don't think is terribly easy
taking with the pun yeah it is crazy
that's what he played and that's the
best move
so we got rid of this night yeah
I saved my bishop pray
and here yeah so this is pretty much
enough to say that you found it there's
several ways forward in this position
you just simple move just protect my
stuff I do not want to Train Queens
okay I don't want to trick means 25 is a
very good move I think he played a
different move in the game but Queen g5
is very good
I assume queen g6 and then you can play
them over that you should probably play
queen takes rook is a crazy audience
suggestion I'll take it okay see ya and
then what's going on here so yeah it's
not this isn't as clear as we would like
it to be that's interesting it's an
interesting idea right that's a move
that we do want to consider in the game
however pawn f7 was played and you took
what the Queen notice let's roll this
one out for some reason rook up 6 and
add stuff if here the point is here and
then you have to decide which way to
take the rook it's not clear which one
is prettier good the answer might be
here so okay so he took with the Queen
there's again several ways he picked a
simple way take the bishop
and now rookie 7 followed by resignation
yeah it's not it's not so easy to not
get made it here because if rook f7 we
can look at this we have this check yeah
yeah we can take here right and no no
those Jokers okay let's see what's the
what's the better wait now yeah here you
hear this okay yeah it looks pretty good
you better take
yeah
this looks like it's a little choice
better okay yes it's quite tricky stuff
and when you give up your night right
here you better see most of that and you
better analyze that correctly because
it's yeah right it's a tempting move
right but then you need to follow it up
you need to understand he's going to
play off six because otherwise as
mentioned yeah maybe I'll play Queen g5
and he just created some space for his
rooks you know lost a lot of material
initially but okay gets it back with
plenty of interest / checkmates black
you know it's very good alright you know
yeah so well there's a reason he's in
the World Championship you know this is
number this is three units for yeah
alright this is number three in this
game let's flip it you find that scary
if you're wrong it's scary yeah after
writing it down and you're wrong then
it's it's pretty scary okay we're gonna
look at this game to pallav versus an
ond the 2010 World Championship okay
so white is beginning to take some
action here on the kingside okay let's
open it up and now with some ideas of
bringing rooks over black played a
seemingly innocent move here and now we
pause it's white to move so there's a
couple tempting moves here
so go ahead and home you can pause your
video I'll give you guys some time the
puzzles are getting harder so I'll give
you guys a little bit of time here this
requires a lot of calculation here drive
it the King away the rook is weak on a
feint he has some coordination problems
in you know coordination problems are
our temporary you give me time just give
me a move just give me one move let me
you know bring my rook over to a better
square just give me one more move g4
what's the point behind this move let me
not do anything what was the is there a
point to g4 because I don't see how
that's immediately a tactic or right it
does let the Queen go across but I'm not
trying to trade Queens here in this
position because now I'm not getting
checkmated and bikes probably doing
really well here maybe we don't want to
trade the Queen's so yeah I don't think
I don't think that's we don't wanna play
g4 and go trade the Queen's we do want
to do stuff over in this sector I'll
give you guys another chance here
tonight by going to alright 9 f 4 so
we're thinking about some night snacks I
guess I'll take it and you want to let's
just try to be safe here
I don't quite see it yeah you're getting
great we're getting close we're getting
close rook g3 what's the what's the
point
let me not do anything what's the point
in the okay now you're going to take on
f6 I take your rook take your night
we're getting very very warm night takes
f5 we're getting close yeah we're
getting warmer surprisingly that's
warmer f6 okay chem West again all night
can West getting all the tactics right
just like usual yes this is quite
interesting and sort of the tactical
point is if the Queen takes which is
what he what he played will earn I you
played King takes the point is you're
kind of tied down to rooks infiltrating
on this side as well as the rooks coming
in the other way and there's some other
you know sneaky stuff going on he took
with the king so yeah if you take with
the Queen now rook h3 so the I think
that's little bit we're gauge 3 and
again you're going to notice you have
some some problems I'm coming in both
ways so it doesn't really matter what
you do if you play here for example I'm
coming in and even though it doesn't
seem like there's there's anything I
don't know what you play here I'm just
bringing my my rooks in no okay but he
took with this King because he doesn't
want to give up control over c7 now
we're at age three and we're going to
see how he follows up here 48
and another problem is okay this also is
a an issue some lines so we protect it
so rig h6 move away one more fun you
play a king e8 if rook g7 we can take
here first if you take with the Queen
rook c7 you take with a king we get to
take on g5 okay and this is sort of an
issue and you can do lots of checking
you can take this pawn and white should
be winning in this position so we can
kind of see why and okay this is
obviously very complicated to calculate
now let's try to play another brilliant
move they play it here or later nobody
look so rook c7 yeah King d8 now only
move you find this move you know win the
World Championship your hero
one g5 is okay but let's it's wrong but
let's look at it because it's
interesting all right you'll notice in
this position this is gonna be important
for later on you can go you know oh it's
like it's so close to checkmate but all
my works are gay
let's just let's not forget that idea
sometimes that is a threat not here so I
hope you guys saw this when you sacked
your knight and then easily found it was
played though you know it's it's nice
when moves are quite remarkable and it's
even nicer when they're actually played
- a six there should be sex okay very
interesting let me let me just test you
when I suppose the HR cow
I mean otherwise re-render inside yeah
so yeah if here then I run this way
we're doing to go does it doesn't matter
yeah I think you have to check with yoga
buzzing I think I think I escaped here
now I think you have to check with the
other rather work in the solution okay
we'll go here I'm kind of worried about
Queen before so don't play Queen before
because I you know Queen before good um
yeah I don't I don't know what I got to
do now what you have to play Queen
before that's too complicated
I'll you know make it even more
complicated you guys figure it out who
knows so that mean this you know there's
there's murky stuff here going on maybe
this is this is okay too
again we're getting very close yeah get
very close you'll notice with this
Bishop out of the way then we have some
direct pressure on the deep on might not
mean anything yet but prepare to be
astounded Bishop to b5
taking away a square from the king and
if you take well then I just simply take
here on d4 and I don't like your chances
okay so I don't take ya what's the big
deal what is the big deal
he took here which is wrong let's let's
just make another move just for
argument's sake here off to remember it
right you can play here
and I'm threatening to take on g5
if you take me rook e8 for example Queen
somewhere if take care just to put this
on the board won the game he went here
this also is wrong and it was sort of
similarly punished
he took here this is the simple way I
think again here is a again the way to
to continue and I don't know what to do
nobody wants to play here this is
looking really good for after white
anyone here and in the game this was
okay this is sort of a simple way to win
and after King takes Jack you have to
give this guy up and then okay you if
you have to trade the Queen's and go
into the same game then you lose and
actually that's one where the game ended
so okay just to come back because this
they're getting tough now yeah this
sacrifice and then to follow it up in
this position with the move Bishop to b5
is just truly fantastic to have seen all
this I've been able to play it creates a
deflection yeah amazing stuff number two
number two this this is one I also quite
like this is Boris Spassky vs Robert
Fischer and this was played in their
1972 much okay so Fischer has the black
pieces here and there's some trades
White has the two bishops things are
looking ok and now Queen to c2 so again
go ahead and pause your video
and see if you can play like Bobby
Fischer it's a tall order but you know
what can be done it's unfair you know
all Fischer games don't test you those
are the score of the match so if you can
read that really small writing you know
the answer so Bishop takes you yeah
Bishop takes a four resigns resigns
after hear a simple maintenance seven
you don't think Bobby would have been
like oh yeah I take hear me yeah okay
yeah so yeah I got a lot of threats here
fire if I remember right this is the
best move let's defend a little
differently I guess King up - and now
let's accuracy I think there's a lot of
moves that win here but let's be
accurate
mmm
where do you want to move tonight yeah
very good
I can go get me did or I can go here
right made it simpler yeah you want to
go forward we have a fork yeah very
pretty mate
very pretty man would you like to have
that mate in the World Championship
though would be a truly beautiful thing
okay and the other problem is if for
example we ignore this not only is our
position super bad
and I can like take care and still take
here and this just is really winning for
me so that's why he wasn't okay we got
one more number one number one all right
this is the position and my number one
pick here is garry kasparov presses in
until they Karpov 1985 white to move
okay you want to remove the defender
okay and yeah you're tanking two things
and then I will protect all my stuff and
then wonder why you did this Wow
check with the bishop anything takes da
yeah this is yes quite it's been quite
an elaborate series of moves here but
yeah I don't know it you got nothing
here um okay this is the number one so
let's let's do try to take our time here
and solve it this is one I think that we
can solve it's just a personal favorite
of mine so number one number one yeah
exactly so again at home if you didn't
hear that you want to solve it this is
your last chance to pause Queen takes t7
don't we all love sacking our Queens to
in World Championships the bishop and he
resigned because after hear you're going
to lose a lot of stuff
yeah I don't even know to play as black
this is just there's you can't really
even save the bishop and that's all
there is to it so um I hope you guys
enjoyed that that nice little top ten
list that we have there
what do you guys think was there any
games that we missed that you thought
should have been involved in this list
what's your number one favorite world
championship tactic let me know like
share subscribe thanks everybody for
coming out tonight